I can go to Jesus sent only to the lost
sheep of Israel. Do we get that
argument? So I can move on.
Sent only to the lost sheep of Israel.
Quoting Matthew. All right. Quoting
Matthew. Huh? All right. Let's see what
our Lord says. If you know how to refute
that, let's move on. Matthew 15:24.
Let's see. Here it goes.
Here's what he's saying. Okay. This is
what he's quoting.
got you. You ain't an Israelite. You
ain't right. He answered, "I was sent
only to the lost sheep of the house of
Israel." All right. Okay. Now,
pay attention. I've answered this 10
zillion times, and I'm going to give you
the article that I wrote before I leave.
So, remind me to give you the article
before I leave. All right. Now, glory to
the father, son, spirit. It is true. You
got to learn your faith. See, this is
why I say in these rebuttals, make sure
to come because you're going to learn
about your Bible. I'm not just repeating
Islam. I'm teaching you by the Holy
Spirit enabling, empowering me to be his
mouth mouthpiece to teach you because
he's our teacher. Everything perfect is
from him. How to understand your Bible,
how to interpret it, how not to
interpret it. So, you're learning how to
understand God's word and then know how
to apply it. And may we all apply it for
the glory of the father, son, and holy
spirit. Okay? It is true that Christ in
his earthly ministry limited himself to
the Israelites and the Gentiles that
surrounded them. So there is no problem.
I affirm this. Amen. He himself
personally on earth
only came to the Israelites because they
were the heirs of the covenant, the
children of the promise. So he came to
them first to announce the fulfillment
of the covenant promises. So they got
first dibs, first chance to believe in
him. That's true. But the same Jesus and
the same gospel says that then he would
send out his disciples as his mouthpiece
representatives in the spirit to now
preach throughout the whole world to all
nations announcing that the king of
Israel who's the king of creation has
come and you must submit to him. Here
you go. Let me not give you the verses.
All right.
You ready?
Why didn't he quote this? I don't know.
Same gospel. I'm not going to any other
gospel.
Same gospel. So, understand what our
Lord meant. What he did not mean. And
I'll repeat it again. Okay? I'll repeat
it again. Here it is. Our Lord to the
disciples whom he limited limited them
to Israel when he was on earth. and the
Samaritans. But later he says he's
prophesying, he's foretelling, the time
will come where you're going to be
witness to all the Gentiles and their
rulers. Why? Here you go. Matthew 10:17
to 20. Okay. Matthew 10:17-20.
Beware of men, for they will deliver you
up to councils and fogg you in their
synagogues, and you will be dragged
before governors and kings for my sake.
Why? to bear testimony before them and
the Gentiles.
So the Lord already announced to them
while on earth. You will be my witnesses
to the Gentiles and their rulers, being
my ambassadors, announcing to them the
gospel. Why do you think Paul was
zealous to get himself arrested to go to
Caesar? Remember when they arrested him?
He made an appeal to Caesar when they
could have let him go because he took
that as an opportunity that the expense
of the Roman Empire. They would ship him
to stand before Caesar and preach to him
the love of Jesus Christ.
So Paul being taught the words of the
Lord took the Lord at his word. The Lord
said this we'd be handed over so he
could be witnesses to rulers. And that's
what Jesus did to Felix, I'm sorry, Paul
did, Felix, Agria, all these rulers, so
he can be Jesus's spokesperson.
So what did our Lord say? The time will
come you will be a witness to the
Gentiles and their rulers.
right
now. He then encourages them when they
deliver you up. Do not be anxious how
you are to speak or what you are to say.
For what you are to say will be given to
you in that hour. You will be given the
right words, the wisdom to refute the
objections on the spot. Why do you
think, brethren, I don't have prepared
sermons? Why do you think I come with an
idea in my mind? But I ask the Holy
Spirit to guide me. And then all of a
sudden, I talk about a variety of topics
that come to my mind because I know the
Holy Spirit is real. He's almighty. He
truly loves us. He's truly filling us
because Christ is risen. He's real. The
Bible is true. And that's why I just
start throwing out stuff because I take
these words to heart. Jesus cannot lie.
He spoke the truth. Because this promise
is not just for the apostles but those
who come after them who believe like
them. Because look what he says in 20.
For it is not you who speak but the
spirit of your father speaking through
you. There's the trinity Jesus God in
the flesh. Aba father and the spirit.
And this shows the spirit is God. Why?
What kind of attributes must the Holy
Spirit have to be with all believers,
starting with the apostles, no matter
where they're at, no matter whom they're
confronting, no matter what the
objection, and have the ability at that
nancond, give them the words and the
wisdom to destroy the objection, leaving
their opponents speechless. And he does
it for all of them at the same time.
What kind of attributes must he have to
know what is being said and the correct
response to give?
And you're telling me the Bible doesn't
teach the Holy Spirit is God Almighty, a
cognizant, self-aware, divine person
equal to the Father and the Son? All
right. So, what we did we catch the
point though? You will be a witness to
the Gentiles. Here it is one more time
in case you missed it. Okay, here you
go.
Okay, here you go. Matthew 10
18. And I got more.
And you will be dragged before governors
and kings for my sake to bear testimony
before them and the Gentiles. All right.
He quoted Matthew. I'm quoting Matthew.
What about Matthew 24:14?
What about this? Did he forget this one?
Matthew 24:14.
Did you forget this? Matthew 24:14.
And this gospel, good news of the
kingdom, will be preached throughout the
whole world as a testimony to all
nations, and then the end will come.
Did he forget this,
guys? Did he forget this one? same
gospel of Matthew.
Matthew 24:14.
So let's just take Matthew 15:24. Ignore
what came before and after. Right?
Are you learning now? I don't expect a
son of the devil, a pagan to accurately
interpret my scripture. But I do expect
Christians who love Jesus to know their
scripture so that he doesn't comb
discombobulate you and caught you off
guard. and cause you to doubt.
Okay, now watch. There's more. I'm not
done yet. Hold on. What about
postresurrection
appearance of Christ? Right after he
rose from the dead, appeared physically
alive to his followers, convincing them
with irrefutable proof he's alive in the
flesh and he's going to reign from
heaven until he returns physically.
What did he say to them before he left?
Matthew 28:16-20.
I love this guy. Mark 2 says that you
have the passion of our Lord. Matthew
28:16-20. Read with me, guys. Read.
Now the 11 disciples went to Galilee to
the mountain to which Jesus had directed
them. And when they saw him, they
worshiped him, but some doubted. I
believe they were doubting whether they
should worship him. Because though he's
been raised in the flesh,
that doesn't mean we should worship him
unless he's more than man. He's God in
the flesh. So they're like confused. Are
we supposed to worship him? No. You
know, I mean, what does this mean?
Because they're shocked. And the Lord
assures them, "Yes, you are to worship
me because I'm God in the flesh, the son
of God, the divine king of all creation.
Now follow the rest of it." And Jesus
came and said to them, "All authority in
heaven and earth has been given to me."
All right? But I thought Jesus was only
for Israel. How can the postresurrected
Jesus say?
All of creation belongs to me, subject
to me in submission to me because all
authority
in heaven and earth is mine. Heaven and
earth, right, refers to all creation.
Everything in heaven, everything on
earth is under my authority. What do you
call someone who is sovereign, who has
sovereign authority, sovereign power
over the entire creation that all of
creation, every in heaven and earth is
subject to him
under his authority in his control
that must do what he says or suffer the
consequences. Last time I checked, you
call him Lord. Lord of heaven and earth,
Lord of all creation, king of all
creation.
Jesus is saying, "Now that I've been
enthroned as the sovereign Lord and
ruler of all creation, all of the
heavens and the earth, everything in
them is mine, subject to me. I rule over
them. I am the Lord of creation. Now go
announce to the world, the king has come
and the king is enthroned." Now, the
great commission makes sense because
notice the order. He first tells them
everything in heaven and earth subject
to me because he's a sovereign lord has
authority over entire creation. So now
go forth to the earth go and proclaim
the nations of the earth. Your king has
come and he's enthroned and he demands
his subjects to submit to him. Therefore
go make disciples of all the tribes of
Israel. No, all nations. Who's going to
do it? They will. Not him. So there is
no contradiction. While on earth, he
limited himself to the Israelites. But
now that he's ascending, he's the one
sending the disciples. You will now go
forth to the rest of the world and
announce your king has come. He sits in
throne. He reigns over you and demands
your allegiance. Who is that king?
Jesus. And he owns all of you.
All nations are his. All right, hold on.
Let's see. Go therefore and make
disciples of all nations, baptizing them
in the name of the father and of the son
and the holy spirit. Wait, no. Jesus
never said three and one. One and three
in your face. Wait. Jesus says in the
name singular of the father and of the
son, holy spirit. So you have father,
son, holy spirit all grouped together
under the same